I do want to talk about chords.
Um,
last time we worked through this idea of the scale and how you can build triads
on each of the members of the,
of the scale.
And we talked about a triad being a configuration of three pitches where you
take the first,
the third,
and the fifth.
The first of the triad,
this is a term that we'll be going over today is called the what?
The root of the triad.
So if we have see Eg,
the c is the root of the triad.
The lowest note of this aggregate of three is the root of the trial.
So we can build triads on each of the members of the scale.
And we said that some of these cords tend to be used a lot more than others.
That the tonic is very important.
The dominant is important.
The subdominant right next to him below the dominant is important.
We're going to be talking about the sixth core today.
We could give that a name,
we could call it the sub mediant,
but that's probably getting too technical.
We'll just call it a six chords.
So we got a one chord billed on the first degree of the scale of five chord
build on the fifth degree of the scale of fourth cord building,
a four chord building,
the fourth degree and a six cord built on the sixth degree.
Now I had an interesting discussion in section this past week.
Uh,
and a couple of really good questions were asked.
I started by saying,
could you come up with any kind of,
well you tell me in 50 words or less what I said in lecture yesterday about
harmony.
How does harmony work?
Can you come up with a visual image of how harmony works?
So we tried out a couple of things.
One of the things that we discussed was this type of imagery here where you'd
have vertically these pillars if you will,
or we could even call.
The more,
I've sort of looked at this sort of called them tree trunks almost.
And these tree trunks were the chords and that the base of each of these chords,
at least conceptually,
theoretically,
is this thing called the root.
So I like this tree metaphor here.
So we've got the root here of the and then the trunk and then up above of
course,
this florid canopy would musically be the what?
The Melanin.
Okay.
So we might think about,
think about that now in the course of this student ask a very good question that
I should have pointed out a long time ago.
And that is when an orchestra plays or in an ensemble plays and they're uh,
they're looking at their meat music and they're reading their music.
Um,
do they play a chord that,
does the violin play a chord and or the trumpets,
each trumpet playing a chord and,
and the viola,
is it playing a chord?
What do you think?
No,
it's just playing one note,
one note of a cord,
one note of a court.
And once again,
we,
our ears hear this aggregate of sound.
We say,
oh,
it's got that,
that,
and we extrapolate out of that information that it is this particular core.
But if you were told to look at what the Yso has on it stands,
nobody's playing the chord there.
Just playing individual notes that all together form a core.
And we pointed out however,
that one individual has a of the music that has all of these parts on it and
that of course is the conductor who has the full conducting score,
the full score in front of him or her.
So that was one interesting question that came up.
So keep this in mind if you're wondering about this idea of quarter three you
could say this is the route and maybe this is the third and that's the fifth.
These other instruments are filling in these things at various spots to produce
this aggregate of the cord a supposing this,
we mentioned this also,
this idea supposedly we have other things kind of running around there.
Without those other things running around,
we would have a good model of homophonic texture,
sort of block chords changing in that fashion.
If you put in other little strands of melody,
it changes it more toward polyphonic texture.
Let's review another point and I'll get to a second question that was asked,
why do we have to change chords?
We talked about this last time,
why did we change chords?
Yeah,
because the melody changes and not all harmonies are concordance.
With every note,
someone asked me,
well,
why are some,
why are some notes?
Why are some notes consonant y or other notes,
dissonance,
and the answer has to do with ratios and string sizes,
lengths of pipe and things like that,
but generally speaking,
pitches that are right next to each other,
very close to each other are dissonant.
If you get a highly irrational ratio like nine to eight,
which is the whole tone or 17 or 18 nine 17 which depending upon your intern
tuning is the half step.
Those irrational ratios are very dissonant or that kind of sound.
But if you allow a little space in there,
let's say you go to a three to two ratio or a six to five,
even a six to five ratio,
it gets more consonant.
Let's see how this would play out here.
For example,
we have the pitch,
see and either no two above or below,
it is dissonant.
These are very close together.
Now let's play this on the piano.
So here's the c.
If I play the d above it,
doesn't it be below it?
It's distant.
But let's say I go down to the aid below it.
No separation between the two pitches.
Now
what about that
consonant or dissonant?
Sounds a lot better.
What about this,
but now going down to the g against the seat,
sounds fine.
Sounds
kind of bland or revenue neutral there about this
sounds sort of nights.
What about this?
No,
not so much.
But if you think about it,
so it's not that if you,
it's not that we're allowing even more space here.
What we've done is taken this pitch and played it all the way down an octave
below it.
So we're actually getting back to this configuration of the pitch right next to
it and we could then of course we could throw that one more time.
Yeah.
And we would get the octave,
which is a,
a duplication of two to one.
So that's,
that's a very wide sort of a ratio there.
So that's something to think about.
The closer to these pitches are together,
the more likely they are to be disappointed and the desire to have some space
added there.
Questions about that?
Okay.
Uh,
let's go on now to talk about chord progression.
Anybody wanting to do,
what's your understanding of what a chord progression is?
If I said core progression,
I think we have that term up on the board today.
What is a chord progression?
Let's see.
You Ghana.
Yeah,
fire away.
Yeah.
Nice and loud.
A little bit louder.
I couldn't hear.
Okay.
Okay,
good.
Excellent.
A sequence of chords that sound good together kind of make sense together.
We could say that sort of March along in a fashion
that kind of makes sense together.
All right.
Then there seemed to be going somewhere and there's this sort of force of polar
gravity in music having to do with some chords,
wanting to go to other chords.
Uh,
so we've got a chord progression.
We've talked about the root of the triad.
The triad is the bottom most pitch of that triad.
Supposing we didn't go see,
gee,
but we decided to start with the chain and put the see up on top c e g c,
well that'd be what's called a cord and version.
We're not going to get into that because that takes us into heavy duty music
theory,
but it's if we don't have root position,
then we've got some other note of the triad in the base and we've got some kind
of cord inversion.
So that's what that particular term means up there.
Uh,
what are we going to do to hear these cores?
How do we hear,
how do we hear Chord progressions?
How do we hear harmony?
What are we listening for?
Again,
obviously we've talked about it again and again and again.
We're going to be listening for the base,
okay?
And all of our musical experience tells us,
listen to melody,
melody is beautiful.
That's what we want to hear.
But now to get a sense of harmony,
we're going to listen to the bass.
And we said last time we want to do two things.
We want to figure out if the harmony is changing and if it is changing,
whether it's changing at a regular or irregular rate.
By regular rate,
we mean that the amount of time that each chord holes is exactly the same.
Every cord holds for the same length of time.
If one cord holds twice as long or only half as long,
then we have an irregular harmonic change,
irregular rate of harmonic change.
So let's begin with our first example here this morning.
It's from Ricard Wagner.
It's the beginning of his ring cycle.
And we're going to listen to this.
Well,
how do we hear the base?
How do we tell if the,
if the harmony is changing,
what I do is try to sing the bass.
I don't know whether it's easier for gentleman or not because our voices are
sort of in the base,
but maybe this is payback time since ladies are always singing the melody.
So we'll,
we'll focus on the base and we'll try to sing the base.
And if we find that in singing the base,
our voice is not changing.
Probably the harmony hasn't changed.
If we have to sing the different pitch,
then probably the harmony has changed.
So let's try that as a initial modus operandi here and we'll see how it works.
So here's an example from Wagner,
see if you can find the pitch and when I hear the sound
louder please.
[inaudible]
did it change?
Yup.
He's keeps that same e flat chord for about six minutes.
Be uh,
at the beginning of the overture to Rheingold and basis of that,
you know,
there's going to be very long opera if he's going to sit there and one cord to
that amount of time is going to go on for a long period of time.
Okay.
Let's listen to an example from the realm of pop music this time.
Uh,
what about this one?
Is it changing?
I think this is Dave Matthews Fan.
What about this one?
See if you can sing,
sing the pitch.
[inaudible]
what about that one?
Did it change?
No.
So that when that,
when uh,
didn't uh,
change either.
We're going to have some that did that change and we're going to work through
this progressively in just a moment.
I want to make one other point before we launch into that and that is the,
this is the following that composers use the rate of harmonic change,
whether it's changing or not changing to sort of make us feel different ways
about the music that we are listening,
uh,
gives a sense of what this music is all really all about.
And since as we will say so much classical music doesn't have a text with it,
we've got to have some markers in there to,
to know,
uh,
what,
what the composer is trying to communicate to us.
Here's the famous example from Mozart's g minor symphony
and so on.
So if,
if I strip away,
there's noodling here,
which is just a kind of Arpeggio patterning of the court and just had the cord
stay there.
Dot Dee Dee Dee.
All right,
so those are the courts underneath notice at the beginning
to two to three,
to four to one to two to three to four,
two at the beginning.
These courts are holding for four measures.
Your total of eight beats a then as it goes on.
Uh
Huh.
What happens here?
Changing on every beat that
they were getting.
Two changes per beat.
So what's happened to the rate of harmonic change here?
Is it regular or irregular?
Highly irregular.
And what is happening to it?
It's getting faster and faster and faster.
So here in the g minor symphony,
we feel this.
Oh,
it's so it's sort of full full of tension,
angst,
anxiety,
perhaps passion.
It's driving somewhere.
And one of the things that's driving it is this accelerating rate of harmonic
change.
The amount of time at each court is holding,
is getting shorter and shorter and shorter.
As we drive into that drive,
into that cadence that the cadences
is simply the end of a musical phrase,
particularly in this case,
the end of a chord progression.
So we've,
well,
we are a point of arrival.
Caden's brings us to a point of arrival.
So that's a piece of Mozart.
Let's turn to a piece of Beethoven now.
Uh,
his symphony number six,
the pastoral symphony.
Let's listen to just a bit of it.
Yeah.
Can you pick out the base?
Can you sing the bass pit?
[inaudible]
now we can.
Okay.
No,
that's fine.
That's why we were stopped right there at my shop right there.
Well,
it's difficult.
It's not easy.
It can you pick out there.
But no,
I mean I was having trouble picking out the base there.
So sometimes you,
you can do it and sometimes you can't do it.
We're going to focus now on some passages where we can do it.
We're going to see how Beethoven is setting up some chord progressions here.
So here we've got,
uh,
let's see.
Um,
we've got some cord set out and we're going to,
let's move it along,
but one 38 or wherever we are there,
we've got some chords set out here and we're in the key of c at this point and
we're going to hear Beethoven go to a tonic chord,
then the subdominant chord than a tonic chord,
then a dominant chord and so on.
We're just going to watch and listen to maybe even sing along with the basis he
changes cords.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
yeah,
for a minute.
And let's work well here that again,
but as you can see,
bomb
hold on that bom,
Bom,
bom,
bom.
And then the,
the changes came a little bit faster and faster.
So let's listen to that again and we will then they get over to here where he's
sitting on the tonic chord and we want to see how long he's going to hold this
tonic chord.
Okay?
Okay.
Regular.
How,
because we're held a long time,
they're now moving faster.
Okay.
So he's up to something here with this heart rate of harmonic change.
We almost fell asleep on that tonic chord.
Uh,
he's doing the opposite of what Mozart,
he's trying to relax this here by slowing down the rate of harmonic change here
that had that health for about 30 seconds.
That tonic core,
almost all classical music and involves irregular rates of harmonic change,
um,
appointed I think will become apparent later on.
But that is perhaps why this is the pastoral symphony,
this idea of being relaxed,
being outdoors among the midst nature and being in a very relaxed sort of state
of mind.
The rate of harmonic change has slowed down considerably here.
Uh,
okay.
Now for the rest of the session today,
what I'd like to do is take examples from the realm of pop music and used them
as paradigms for what happens in the world of classical music.
Why would I do that?
Why,
when dealing with harmony and baselines,
do I want to start by focusing on popular music and then apply those principles
to classical music?
What does pop music do for us?
It's very helpful,
Marcus.
Okay.
It's not like it is very regular.
Marcus.
I'm always telling my kids don't like,
like no,
it is indeed very regular.
So,
uh,
it is indeed very regular.
So that's,
that's one thing.
And by regular we mean these patterns keep repeating again and again.
So Marcus is absolutely right.
That's the big ticket item.
It's,
it's regular.
It oftentimes repeats and it can be symmetrical in that sense.
Another observation,
Roger.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's another point.
It's more obvious because it probably fewer lines there so that you can focus on
the primary line,
the basic line,
the baseline.
Yeah.
So there's,
uh,
it's probably simpler in that sense.
Any other observations?
Well,
here's one other that you might not have thought of a,
and that is that most of the chords in rock music in particular tend to be root
position chords a as,
and for that reason,
they're easier to hear when you start getting an inversion gone.
What node is that?
What Chord is that?
That obfuscates the issue.
So because so much popular music,
particularly rock music,
has those chords in root position,
we can track them more readily.
And then finally we can add that the idea that may be with a lot of,
uh,
electronic basis and things like that that they play,
they tend to play the bass just louder.
Okay.
So all of these factors,
particularly the idea of regularity and repetition.
So let's take a couple of examples here.
Now,
let me go over and look at my list.
Um,
okay.
I think we have something.
I've chosen something called badly drawn.
Boy,
I had this in my collection.
Anybody ever heard of this is okay,
one,
two,
this is not okay.
Three.
So this is,
is that,
is it direct,
badly drawn boys or boy board?
What?
Singular.
Okay.
Um,
we're going to hear just a few seconds of this.
See if you can determine the,
how many cords we have here,
whether we have a core change.
If so,
how many cords or are involved in this core change and are they changing and
irregular or your regular rate.
Okay.
But they were before the corporate counsel's office starts getting on my case.
Uh,
what about that?
Regular or irregular regular ball.
And then we go onto the next one.
And how many cords were involved?
Their difference of opinion shut.
How many,
okay,
well let,
let's hear it again.
I think we,
let's do,
I'm sorry Linda.
Let's do it again and see if we can figure,
figure this out where it wasn't planning to do this,
but we have time.
Let's do it.
Okay.
So to Edward.
Um,
so we have just two chords here.
Just change it back and forth between two.
Uh,
here's another example.
Um,
Justin Timberlake.
Sorry,
but it's a good example.
Let's listen to this.
How many cords or involve regular or irregular?
Huh?
Regular or irregular?
Hmm.
Let me think.
In regular.
Raise your right hand.
Raise your left hand.
You think it's your regular,
yeah,
it's regular and with each cord was holding for two beats there in Dupo meter.
How many cords where they're all together?
Yeah,
I think there were four chords there.
So we had changed.
Yes,
it was changed.
It was regular and it happened to involve,
uh,
four chords.
Okay.
Pop Music.
We've been using some pop music here.
We've talked about why we use the pop music.
Let's talk about what the difference between pop and classical music.
If we've touched on this a little bit before,
but let's,
uh,
let's play with this again.
Uh,
you know,
let's say you go home for Thanksgiving break and your grandmother and says,
what have you been doing?
It all had been taking this course and music.
We've been sending classical music and some popular music.
She says,
what's the difference?
Tell me what's the difference between popular music and classical music?
How would you explain to your grandmother what the differences,
maybe six,
seven,
eight different bullet points here.
Okay.
Who could get us started?
We've talked about some of these already having to do with the nature of the
harmony that pop music tends to have a simpler harmonies and that those
harmonies tend to be more repetitious,
that they tend to have harmonies that have cords in root position.
And here's one other thing.
You might not think of a and then I'm going to stop and I'm gonna let you add
things here.
They tend to be just triads,
whereas in classical music
you could have a try,
but we could also add a seventh node,
one,
three,
five,
seven,
that kind of thing.
It gets more distant then the more notes that you add there.
So classical music does involve more complex chords.
Okay,
what else?
What else here?
Okay.
Um,
Oscar
pop,
pop music tends to have a vocal part.
Why?
Okay.
Well,
because it wants to be popular.
Maybe a circular argument there.
Well,
okay,
but,
but if,
if,
if you're going to have a singer,
what's that singer going to be singing?
Okay.
Uh,
uh,
a melody.
Well,
album,
but classical music has melody,
you know,
we have a violinists play a melody.
If you have a singer,
a singer is going to be singing a
a text,
right?
And we've talked about this before,
that classical music,
probably 85% of it does not involve a text.
And that's,
that's a whole different ballgame because then you have to communicate meaning
in a completely different sort of way.
Maybe you communicate meaning by slowing down your harmonic motion to make us
feel relaxed.
So that,
that each of these with,
with pop music,
you'd have,
you know what the thing means principally because of the text.
But with,
with the classical music,
you've got these sort of subliminal symbols in their subliminal signifiers that
we've got to pick up on.
And we'll be talking more and more about that.
So we do have debts.
A very important point that Oscar ridges there.
We've got text in pop music that tells us what this music means.
Anything else?
Uh,
Caroline.
Okay.
If you go to a hear of symphony of mid Beethoven on each movement will probably
last 15 minutes.
If you put on a CD,
you know,
we could have a what?
What's the timing on the just Dustin Timberlake thing there or any one of the
trash pickup?
The Duke of Earl one there.
Did they give this timings a,
okay,
I can't read it,
but two minutes and 50 seconds,
two minutes.
This is only two minutes,
three minutes and 20 seconds.
That kind of thing.
They're short.
Uh,
whereas Beethoven has mentioned as much longer.
What does that,
what does that opportunity of length provide us?
It provides us the opportunity to be more diversified in terms of the mood of
the music.
So in classical music you can have rather wide,
uh,
mood swings.
Remember we had in that one piece
and then,
oh,
it was a modulation tying them together,
but there was,
were completely different sentiments.
Usually with a piece of popular music,
you get a single ethos,
a single feeling,
the single mood associated with the piece and the piece will tend to be shorter.
Okay.
Anything more that we could push on that?
Yeah.
Okay.
That's it.
Yeah.
Most classical music is written down and we've talked to,
we spent a lot of time talking about that and most popular music,
well virtually all of it.
Although after the fact people try to write it down,
you can,
you can go by a score of,
of meat of the Beatles for example.
Although they didn't design this initially with with music,
but after the fact people sort of listened to it and and and Co and make,
make written full put in written form what had originally been just an orally
can see artistic statement.
Anything else,
Raj?
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh,
so we've got the difference between acoustical instruments,
which are sort of natural wood and strings and that sort of thing and
electronically amplified sound in which it might be sent to a mixer or perhaps a
synthesizer that could play with those partials that we talked about and maybe
turn a clarinet,
somebody playing it a keyboard and you want that keyboard to sound like a
trumpet where you just turn a mixing board and you can get those pitches to
sound like a trumpet.
Or,
for example,
let's say your share and you're getting into your early sixties,
and you really can't hit that high note and the more you can get electronically
that particular sound to be enhanced.
And let's say you can't hold that.
Let's say Pavarotti at the end of his life,
couldn't hold notes as long as he could when he was recording in 1978.
Well you can just,
uh,
an engineer will just sit there and isolate that second of sound and,
and give the times three come in and boom,
we'll look at poverty.
Hauled out that note.
Well it's,
it's the miracle of the engineer and not the singer.
So,
uh,
there,
there are a lot of acoustical things,
sort of tricks of synthetic things going on in pop music.
Yeah.
Chord progression,
but also the structure of the piece.
Music.
There's often a couple of verses and the chorus and a bridge and you can predict
each different movement of the piece much more regularly.
Couldn't say it better myself.
Say That nice and loud so everyone can hear it.
The structure of a popular pieces,
often more predictable and pattern.
And vs in bridges and courses.
Whereas with the classical music,
you really can't predict what part of the movement you're at as well as you can.
Exactly.
And that ties in with the harmony also,
which is also a lot more predictable.
And so generally speaking,
what we ended up with classical music,
it's much more diversified.
It's much more varied.
It's much more complex.
We've got contrapuntal lines operating in it.
It has the capacity for expansion.
It can take us through the full plan,
a plea of human emotions within one particular composition.
And it perhaps allows the opportunity for more personal interpretation exact,
exactly what does this music mean?
More personal interpretation because we're not tied to attach,
we're not linked in to a particular text that tells us what it's about.
So those are just a few,
few ideas as we,
as we pursue this.
Well,
what I'd like to do now is,
uh,
move here to a couple of additional pieces and we're going to use an example of
pop music.
Now with a three chord chord progression.
We've heard,
I guess it was badly drawn board boys.
They're with a two chord chord progression.
Now we're going to hear a beach boys,
I guess with a three chord chord progression,
and it's going to be subdominant dominant tonic.
Is it regular or irregular?
[inaudible]
there.
Can you sing that base?
You sing it for me.
Here's the ton of from bump.
MMM,
good,
good.
Louder.
That's it.
Okay.
So that's all you gotta do.
And you can hear the
link for twice as long as the other.
So you've got irregular rate of harmonic change.
So that's one,
four,
five,
one.
Let's go to a little bit more of Beethoven.
And we're going to go now to the last movement of his pastoral symphony.
And I keep hitting on the pastoral symphony cousin,
two weeks or maybe three,
maybe three weeks.
We're going to go here,
I guess the Saybrook Orchestra play the pastoral symphony.
So I'm spending a little extra time on the pastoral symphony here and the last
movement opens with this sort of sale.
We have these pitches.
Uh,
and I'll will listen and you can tell me what instrument is playing it.
so we have those sorts of sounds.
Woo.
And then another instrument will come in with
and play that.
It's all,
these are all notes of AC.
Try it and see
all notes of the sea trial.
All notes have a seat right now we happen to be in the key of f here.
So that means he starting out with the dominant,
which,
which gets us to the point that all pieces have to end in the tonic one way or
another,
but not all pieces to begin with the tonic.
So this one happens to begin with a sort of dominant chord.
So this is a little bit of dominant preparation.
So tell me what instruments are playing here
and then the strings coming.
So let's pause it right there.
So what was the first instrument?
Anybody picked that up and at one point on the quiz or a test?
Next week we are uh,
on Thursday we'll give you three,
at least three playings Robert Clarinet.
Yes,
it was a clarinet up there.
Nice and hot.
And then another instrument came in with,
what instrument was that?
French horn.
Yeah.
But notice if we take this,
we're good.
Back to that same idea of the Octa,
the fifth,
the fourth and the third.
So,
so it's again sort of primordial this,
this particular acoustical basis of so much of music.
So that's our dominant preparation.
And then the melody starts,
so let's listen to this.
Let me play it here a little bit.
Yeah.
So it has a kind of antecedent consequence for your structure with the,
once we get up there,
that's sort of the end of the antecedent phrase,
and we'll have a core change.
What we're working with here at the same chords,
we've sort of gone from the beach boys to Beethoven here.
We've got the same chords operating.
It's going to be a one core,
then a four chord,
and we'll drop down for the forecourt.
Then we'll come to a five core to a one core,
two,
four core to a five core to a one court,
just as we were doing with the beach.
So let's just continue,
I think Linda,
please.
Yeah,
with the Beethoven,
sorry.
Oops.
Did we lose our friend Beethoven?
Oh,
we'll will resuscitate Beethoven here.
How many of you have ever heard this before?
While Linda's is getting this set?
Let's see if we could sing it together and because we're going to do this in a
different way to say
la,
la La la La la La la La,
la La.
Okay.
So let's see this.
That's the melody.
And we're going to sing.
Hello.
Oh aw.
Bomb beneath.
We're gonna sink Beethoven's base beneath Beethoven's melody.
Okay.
This is,
this is the intro.
That's fine.
We'll listen to it.
Here comes the horn.
Oh,
mom.
MMM
[inaudible].
So that's an example of a classical composer,
admittedly in a pretty straight,
straightforward situation using the same three chord core progressions we find
in the beach boys.
Let's enlarge this further.
Let's move to a four chord chord progression.
We're going to switch the board.
Jacob,
if you could give me a hand,
just tick taking that around and we're going to go to the kind of music that I
grew up with as a kid.
It's always fun.
This is gene Chandler and the Duke of Earl.
So we're going to listen to a little bit of it and we're going to chart the base
here.
Trying to remember,
I think actually is in the same key as Beethoven,
and then we'll see exactly what it is that he's doing here.
So we're gonna let's try to lock in on the base.
Here we go.
Ooh,
wow.
Nothing can stop a due bill.
Good.
Yeah.
And let's move it up to about 30 39 or so.
Uh,
so we've got four chords operating here and they're changing regularly.
What are those four chords?
Well,
we talked a little bit about this before.
Now we have,
which called a six cord and we're not moving directly to the four chord.
We're moving to another court here,
a six cord,
which happens to be a minor chord.
Here's the four card.
There's two,
the one.
So you are seeing this nice and loud for me.
Please move.
Bomb.
There's a Tenae.
Why did he go?
Aw,
good.
One more time.
Yeah.
Louder.
Hello.
Okay.
Now Watch what happens as we continue with this one six,
four,
five,
one progression.
Uh,
do we have a regular or irregular rate of change here?
Let's go onto the next section.
Okay?
Yes.
Yay.
Shit.
Yes sir.
We'll stop it there.
So what happened in that Middle Section?
Yeah.
Good.
Yeah,
y'all.
And then we went on and on and on and on.
The longer,
longer,
longer than am I,
Blah Blah.
But it was the same pattern.
He just,
he just elongated each measure by its same amount.
So we had a harmony changing,
uh,
on each measure.
And then in that middle section,
each cord was changing at the rate of two measures.
So the whole piece then would be a piece involving irregular rate of change.
Your regular rate of change.
The entire piece.
Okay.
So,
uh,
that's the Duke of Earl progression,
the basic one six,
four,
five one.
Now I play a passage of Mozart,
uh,
um,
a symphony by Mozart here,
uh,
that he wrote at the ripe old age of nine years,
nine years.
This is Mozart at age nine.
He had actually written a couple of symphonies.
By this time.
This is as a symphony number five and B flat.
Uh,
so let's listen to this.
We're just going to listen and see if,
see if anything strikes you as interesting.
Okay.
We can pause it there.
I think we're just shipping to keep right on going just to get the point across
with just let it run.
Okay.
That's enough of that.
So that's Mozart using the Duke of Earl harmony.
Um,
not really.
This was a point I brought up in my section the other day.
Is there a lots of legal cases where people try to sue somebody else for
stealing a song that he's tried to sue them for stealing a baseline or something
like that?
You can get away.
You can sue people for stealing melody.
You can never,
there's a strong legal precedent for not being able to make a claim about a
stolen base because these bases are limited in number.
They involve rather simple harmonic progressions and they'd been used over the
centuries.
It's not as if gene Chandler said around here studying Mozart symphonies.
I don't know.
Maybe he did.
He said,
oh,
I like that.
Harmonic progression.
I'm going use that here.
No,
everybody's been using that sort of since time in memorial at least since the
16th century.
Now let's go on here to listen to some music of Rossini,
a composer Giacomo Rossini coming after Mozart.
Uh,
and he likes Chord progressions to,
so we're going to listen to a passage of,
of Rossini and see what he does by way of his cord selection.
So the point of this is once you get these kind of progressions locked in your
ears,
you go to a concert and you can begin to chart what the heart of what the piece
is doing in terms of its harmony.
Yeah,
you're not going to be able to hear all of it and the deed,
you may not be able to hear most of it.
I don't hear most of it,
but there are moments and there are moments that give me pleasure when I can
say,
oh yeah,
that's what he's doing there.
I might not know what key he's in.
I don't really care what keys in,
cause I don't have absolute pitch.
Uh,
but I can find,
well maybe it's a one six,
four,
five one chord progression or one five one progression or one four,
five one.
Um,
we,
you'll get different kinds of patterns.
A pocket bell base pattern is,
and another one.
So let's listen to a pattern that Rossini is using here in this opera overture.
First thing we got to do is sort of lock on to the tunnel.
Just taking the wild.
Let's stop it right there.
It's just fun.
It's taking me a while to lock on to that time.
I don't know,
the base isn't as loud as it in some of the pop needs will give dumb,
but I think it,
but I think that's what the tonic is so,
so don't be,
don't despair if you don't initially land on the tonic here.
It takes a while.
So,
but I think we've got to identify,
all right,
let's go on,
right?
Yeah.
Pom Pom Pom.
Paul,
what would you guess those two chords are?
If he said this is the tonic bomb.
Okay.
Other,
it's probably going to be the dominant.
You ever hear music rocking back and forth repeatedly between two courses is
probably tonic dominant tonic.
I remember we had that even with the Strauss,
but he played that tonic dominant tonic dominant Tanika so if you're two cores
rocking is probably tonic and dominance.
Okay.
Let's see how he expands this a little bit.
[inaudible]
what was that?
Well that's the Duke of Earl passage,
right?
So you're sitting there and Woolsey Hall,
New Haven Symphony or whatever in New York Philharmonic.
Oh yeah.
It's a Duke of Earl passage.
So,
uh,
yes,
it was the one six mm
progression.
All right,
let's see what happens next.
So what happened
connect was he then started to run that faster bomb he,
Bob,
Bob twice as fast as it had been before.
Changing rate of Armani pattern.
Okay
there.
What was that?
Bom Bom.
Bom.
Bom pump pump.
Pump.
Pump,
pump.
Pump up.
What chords?
They're probably
Daniel,
what do you think?
What courts there
just dominate Italian palm,
palm,
Palm,
palm bump,
bump,
going faster and faster.
And then what happens?
[inaudible]
the end of that was all just a ton.
And he just sat there on the tunny forever.
It's a good example of sort of realtime in psychological time in music.
You knew it was time to start clapping.
As soon as that core hit that stop going back and forth,
tonic dominant,
just sitting there.
That piece is over.
The rest is just a big mud pie in your face.
Okay?
It's just tonic or maybe throwing an anchor overboard to bring this ship to an
end.
Whatever sort of analogy or visual image you want to bring to it.
But it's,
the piece has ended.
Even though we are continuing to hear sound harmonically,
psychologically,
we know we're finished when he hits that particular topic.
Okay.
I think our time is up.
I'll see you Wednesday evening and look for an email,
uh,
early this afternoon about individual help tomorrow afternoon.